hi guys Lucy here with a breaking
gamespot news story it's time to grab
your hidden blade scramble up a building
only to spectacularly jump off because
those assassins creed rumors were right
today Ubisoft officially announced
Assassin's Creed rogue a new game in the
series coming to xbox 360 and
playstation 3 this autumn alongside
Assassin's Creed unity which is
launching only for xbox one playstation
4 and pc playing as shade Patrick Cormac
no not Game of Thrones Shay this one's a
dude you switch allegiances from
assassin to Templar after being betrayed
by the Brotherhood but being a Templar
means you'll have access to a bunch of
new weapons for use on both land and sea
yes all you fans of naval combat rejoice
you'll be navigating a ship called the
Morrigan across the North Atlantic so
hopefully they'll be shandies of plenty
other confirmed locations include the
appalachian river valley and a reimagine
new york that's according to the reveal
announcement from game informer
according to game director martin
coppell Assassin's Creed rogue completes
the North American saga started with
Assassin's Creed 3 and assassins creed 4
black flag it gives previous generation
console owners an exclusive opportunity
to experience fan requested features
such as playing as a Templar and
although AC rogue and AC unity asset on
different continents rogue takes place
during the Seven Years War which
contributed to Frances financial woes so
it's quite possible that the two stories
will overlap no official release date
for Assassin's Creed rogue has been
announced but a previous report
suggested it might be launching on
November the 11th which is a couple of
weeks after Assassin's Creed unity so
what do you reckon are you ready to head
into the Animus twice in one month or do
you think it's a bit of overkill let me
know in the comments for all the latest
gaming news stay tuned to gamespot
you